all right
hi everyone thank you for attending this
talk my name is ayal i'm a data
scientist at babylon health uh just to
get it out of the way i'm not
representing my company but rather
myself
for those of you who were in hana's talk
that's great you got some a lot of
information that actually won't go over
but yeah i think i'll start at this
stage so one of the things that i enjoy
most as a data scientist and i'm sure a
lot of you is
modeling for challenging and interesting
problems but what i find even more
thrilling is being able to
get data such that to test your models
to see how well you've done
and um
one of my first tastes of getting
feedback from real life impact was in
2016 the details don't matter but uh
just briefly i was working on doing
consulting for a midsize restaurant
chain uh doing some marketing for them
and
i i was doing a project which i call
snail mail a b testing and again the
details don't really matter except for
the fact that we were sending them
coupons via mail and so it took months
to get the data back
and so i summarized the project both as
a successful both as a success and as a
failure the reason i consider it
successful is because my machine
learning models really managed to
identify people that are were more
likely to go into the restaurant and
make purchases
and i managed to beat their standard
marketing firm but it was a failure not
only because the um they didn't continue
the contract uh with my company but me
as a statistician i actually failed in
the sense that i peeked into the data uh
before it was ready under the pressure
of the clients uh and that's known
that's known as the peaking and so what
i failed to know at the time and is the
topic of today is what's the stopping
criteria how do you know when you've
collected enough data in order to have
statistically robust uh results
and so um this is a key feature in
hypothesis testing which is a very broad
field so there's no way that i'm going
to cover all of it but my objective is
to give you a flavor so you can better
understand for yourself uh the reason i
feel this is important is because this
is the first thing that an analyst is
asked for when starting a project how
much data do you need and the common
practice to do is to do some sort of
power analysis in which one goes into a
website calculator puts in the
parameters and then kind of wigs and
wings it later on and so i feel it's
kind of like a dark art and i looked
into it a bit more and here i'm going to
present a few opinions that i've
collected upon the time and basically
i'm echoing a lot of ideas
in the excellent blog posts and book by
john krusk
just a bit about myself i've been doing
predictive modeling and analysis for 15
years in various domains i started off
in astronomy later on in consulting and
most recently in biotech and in
healthtech uh and
if i do my job correctly my objective is
for you to have a better understanding
about experimentation if it's first of
all by better understanding how to
analyze sample data and as a consequence
you'll be able to be better at budgeting
for your next experiment
i have two main take-home messages is
that you should as an experimentalist
you should be moving on from frequentist
to bayesian methods and of course with a
focus on the theme of this talk which is
that precision should be your main
objective that should be your goal and
uh the second message of course it's
kind of trivial but it's worth noting
precision is expensive
so that's it in terms of motivation
i don't assume any knowledge of
hypothesis testing and so i'll give a
very brief introduction to that to those
who do have experience i will highlight
a lot of things that i'm sure that
you'll find interesting first of all
i'll pose the problem of the standard
practice of the stop criterion which is
likely to lead to biases
and so i'll talk about that as a problem
and then i'll talk about the the the
solution suggested by john krusk which
is precision is the goal so we'll get
into that and then i'll summarize by
talking about real life considerations
uh it
i don't think there's gonna be much time
but i do have a sample calculator my own
online so maybe in the question time if
you're interested it's a work in
progress uh that i'm interested in
developing further
i will start with an apology
i prepared a very long talk and i don't
have all that time so the the slides are
are available online here you have uh
the the link uh and feel free to to
speak with me later the main reason is
that not only was i learning the topic
more in depth but i've been learning
parenthood we have our first newborn i
have we haven't um we're not
putting the um or gorgeous face on
social media but if you're interested i
will be passing on my phone so you can
actually take a look for yourself no
okay of course i won't do that but yeah
but feel free to pick me up after talk
about anything
i talk about today or about parenthood
um cool so we'll start with uh with what
hypothesis testing is basically it's
when you collect data in order to answer
a question most of the time we think
about a b testing but generally speaking
it's when we want to
rule out some sort of parameter value or
more interestingly when we want to
confirm a parameter value i talked about
redeeming coupons for a restaurant in my
marketing example but uh but otherwise
you can think of cure rates of drugs
polling data and the emphasis of this
talk will be on a very simple case is
how fair is a coin that i'm tossing the
reason being because it's because it's
very simple and well defined
mathematically and also to a very useful
analogy for all the other examples that
i mentioned right here i'm focusing on
rate statistics meaning anything between
0 to 100
but you can use this as analogy for
anything continuous so you can imagine
for example a drug how well it changes
the blood level pressure um but so um
yeah
and what is the main challenge of
hypothesis testing well basically you
cannot apply your hypothesis to the
whole population hence you have to use a
sample and a sample you should use it as
an indication of the result that you can
expect from population but obviously you
cannot consider it as equal
and for that reason we
and the reason for that is because you
might land on an extreme case as we'll
see throughout and and that's why we
want to use statistics to better
understand
to relate between our observation to
what we think the underlying truth
actually is
and that brings us to the stop criterion
of course we want to know how how much
data do we actually need how much of the
population do we have to sample and so
of course there's always going to be
constraints and
and when we work with stakeholders
they're always going to want to do it as
cost effectively as possible and of
course there might be ethical issues for
example clinicians might want uh might
want might be dealing with a drug that
has deleterious effects and so you would
want to stop that as soon as possible
uh and
there are various mechanisms of uh of
doing
statistical significance uh this is by
far the most popular a frequentest
approach called a null hypothesis sigma
test i have to not think nh the british
nhs
medical services when i say the acronym
uh and and the reason that it's it's
it's highly used is because it's fairly
easy to calculate and familiarity it's
within all the textbooks it was created
way before the invention of the computer
and that actually brings it to its
downfall is that it's not really
understood by non-experts because it's
really not intuitive and the main thing
that i'll
key point that i'll talk about and i'll
emphasize today the fact that it does
not you cannot use it to accept a
hypothesis hypothesis as a poster
bayesian message that we'll look into so
you heard various talks today about
beijing
beijing talks if you're still not
comfortable with the difference between
beijing and frequentest i like to i like
to uh um
use this as my go-to uh thought frame of
thought so it's just how we approach
probability so for example frequentists
rely on something called the likelihood
what that means is that you assume an
underlying hypothesis and then you ask
what's the probability of me collecting
the data let's start with our first
example the coin toss you you toss a
coin ten times seven times it's it's
heads and so you say
assuming a fair coin meaning a 50 50
slip split between heads and tails then
um what's the probability of getting
getting seven out of ten that's how
frequent this thing's uh bayesians think
in terms of posteriors they use
likelihoods but the bottom line is a
posterior in which what
the anchor is the data given the data
what's the probability of my hypothesis
given we have got seven heads out of ten
tosses what's the probability of her our
coin being fair at a rate of fifty
percent or unfair let's say sixty-five
percent
uh
so when they know when should you use
frequencies versus bayesian as a general
rule of thumb my opinion is always use
bathing bayesian unless it's really too
expensive for your use case in uh in
that case hopefully you have large
enough data in which the frequentest
invasion should use should result in a
similar uh result but um but bayesian
the main advantage of it is that it's
much more descriptive um that than than
than then frequent this because
frequency gives you a point measurement
or beijing gives you a full distribution
and so it has and so that in that sense
it's much more interpretable but then
again it is more expensive so you do
have to do that cost benefit a
calculation
all right so all that that was
introduction now we'll get uh into the
stop criterion
um
so again i mentioned coin statistics the
reason i'm going to use that is that
it's very simple well well defined
mathematically um and we'll see just by
tossing a a hypothetical coin about the
problem with peking that i mentioned
before and i'll point why the nhst
method is problematic
uh and so well what's the stop criterion
the stock criterion is subjective
decision that someone has to make either
it's an analyst or it's the developer
who has to uh write the al uh um
equation within some sort of algorithm
and of course there's the again the the
pressure from your stakeholders to do it
as cost effective to so to stop as soon
as possible and and here we'll see uh
why normally that's not a good idea and
um later on we'll see what i suggest
that we should be doing uh so just
before we get into results let's look at
the nhst what it is the stop criterion
is when uh we have a metric called p
value which i'll soon define which is
when it's smaller by some false negative
rate parameter called alpha
so
and so here's the definition of the
p-value so it's the likelihood that
that
our observation
that the null value
might be larger than the observation so
it's easier to understand it within a
graph so here we have our point metrics
we have the null value and let's say we
have our observation and so what we draw
is some sort of likelihood function it
doesn't matter what it really is if it's
a normal or or t distribution that
detail doesn't matter some sort of
distribution and the p value is just
this it's the probability that our that
our our our null value is going to be
larger uh oh sorry that our the
probability of our data is larger than
our observed value this is what's called
the one-sided test more generically what
people do is is oh sorry just before
that uh if p value is larger than the
null hypothesis than the alpha then we
reject the null hypothesis if it is um
larger then we're inconclusive what do
we do in terms of exclusive sometimes we
collect more data sometimes we come with
something else again people wing it
normally
that was one-sided two-sided is when
actually so here one side is when you
want uh you're testing for the
alternative to be better but in most
cases it's actually uh um two-sided in
which you don't actually care which is
better so in the case my marketing
framework is the other marketing firm
from the point of view the customer they
don't care like who's ever better that's
what that's all they care about
um okay so so with that definition here
we can go through some examples uh so
what i'm doing here is i'm testing the
null hypothesis for fair coin where i'm
starting out actually with a fair coin
so just to explain what these two graphs
are here i'm actually looking i'm
looking at the the cumulative sum
average just by tossing 1 500 times so
each time i'm stopping and i'm
calculating what the the what i think
the coin value is here i highlight it
it's very hard to see sorry about that
here is the actual ground truth at 50
percent and i purposely chose an extreme
example in which you can see it's highly
negative and so here it's highly
negative eventually it will add some
thought towards 50 but here you can see
the p value at each i get each iteration
i take the p value and here you can see
at the commonly used five percent it
will actually stop uh and so if that's
our stop criterion then the observer
will ignore all this information later
on and in their opinion it has they have
a a very biased coin at like 45
and that's their opinion okay that was a
very extreme example so you know with
anecdotes you can't so you can't
get any real conclusions in order to do
that you want to do this like thousands
of times and that's what i do in this
graph so just to explain what this is
and apologize i moved over to log scale
over here so what i'm doing is
just to explain like here we stopped at
let's say 340. and so how abnormal is
that well let's look at this over here
here i'm doing iterations and here i'm
doing a cumulative proportion of the
decisions we have two options either
reject or inconclusive so here let's say
340 is about here and so i can see about
just about 30 or 40 percent of the time
when we stopped
the toss
at 340 or before we rejected the null
hypothesis even though we have the
benefit of knowing that that's our
ground truth so we know we're doing it
incorrectly and so john prisk's claim is
that if you wait long enough meaning you
toss the coin enough times you're always
going to get a false alarm you at some
stage you're going to stop because the
p-value is going to go below your
threshold in our example five percent
okay um so that was a fair coin let's
look at an unfair coin and an unfair
coin well you you want to reject the
null hypothesis so here i'm using an
unfair coin of 65 percent and here you
can see after 200 uh tosses you get the
right correct result 100 of the time
you're going to reject the hypothesis
which is a good thing but now i'll show
the bad is that you're still going to be
biased in what sense well
this histogram shows what is the sample
success rate
at the time of the decision and so just
just to explain what this is this is the
ground truth this is 65
and here you can see that the mean of
all of those rates is at 72 percent the
reason being is that you have another
negligible amount of samples that happen
to be 80 or 80 percent or more so you
are getting the right thing you are
reject the null hypothesis but then you
you want to say well how much is the
rate and you're actually getting the
wrong rate so you're overestimating what
you're really doing okay and so that's
the main flaw so how does this even make
sense right because you think well each
calling toss is independent from the
previous one well it makes sense because
um what's not independent is when you're
stopping right
you always stopped like north or or or
or above um uh um above let's say 60
over here actually here's one on on the
other side but mostly you're not filling
in this region over here because you're
biased towards uh stopping w when you're
higher
in our case uh because we're using a
highly biased one uh um at 65.
uh and so that's why we get uh uh uh we
get a bias so so uh before we got a
confirmation bias right we were
rejecting uh uh um a fair coin
uh and now when we're using an unfair
coin when we're not getting the correct
result it's getting too high okay so one
way that you can actually um
you can reduce this within hst is
actually lowering alpha if you use one
percent or 0.1 percent of course you'll
be able to reduce these biases but it's
at the expense of collecting more data
right that's point number two precision
is expensive
okay so frequentist i i presented the
problem uh can bayesian methods
magically
improve for this because everybody
thinks oh bayesian cells for everything
and so that will be our next top there
are various bayesian methods um this is
a fairly new field uh i mean that's
propagating uh um
and so here i'll just show a very
popular one hdi uh with rope and in
order to do so i'll introduce two topics
one is the the
confidence interval that that bayesians
use called hdi and uh something that's
called a good enough built in hypothesis
testing
so what an hdi basically is it's um you
take your posterior and then what you
want to define is where 95 of the mass
is basically you scan from top to bottom
and you find where 95
of the mass is and so here i'm just
highlighting in this cartoon
um
normally people use like 95 the previous
talk was 94. there's online discussions
maybe we should use 89 just to show how
arbitrary the number is um but uh yeah
but we'll just stick with uh 95 because
people are familiar with that number uh
the next topic is rope so here i'm just
taking a direct quote quote from john
krusk's book basically is you just want
to define based on your domain
what region is kind of equivalent to to
your null value like in in my simple
task i'm just doing anything between 45
to 55
as far as i'm concerned is equal to my
50 percent of course if you work in a
mint then that will be unacceptable you
want it like 0.1 or lower
but just for the purpose of this example
we're going to take a wide range of like
10
and so the stop criterion just says if
your hdi is completely within the rope
or completely without
then you'll stop collecting and then
you'll assess where if it's completely
without
outside then you'll reject if it's
completely within then you'll accept
that was two examples here i'll go
through actually all of them so these
are two rejecting sent two rejecting
examples to the right and to the left uh
then you have one accepting scenario and
then you have actually three scenarios
in which you're inconclusive because
you're straddling either the left or the
right or actually the the hdi is broader
than the rope and then you have to
decide am i collecting more data do i
have a budget for it or i'm just getting
back to my stakeholder and just saying
yeah we don't have statistical
significance what do we do what i'm
doing right over here is i'm using the
same exact extreme example from before
remember we rejected it at after
340 uh tosses which was right about over
here here you can see actually we're
accepting uh the null hypothesis at
about 900 okay that's this figure over
here and here i'm just showing you how
how the hdi actually gets short and
shorter as you small and smaller as you
collect more data i'm already alluding
to the precision aspect that we'll get
to later
so of course this is anecdotal now we
want to see
on on many simulations and so if before
you saw that we always rejected with the
bayesian that corrects for it here you
can see we're accepting the null
hypothesis and that's the big win for
bayes so that's first one of the one of
the first arguments why you want to use
base which you can start accepting null
hypothesis but there is a problem with
this specific base method in which you
can see that you're still rejecting the
null hypothesis even though that's our
ground truth you're still rejecting it
20
of the time right so that's problematic
and um let's look at the unfair quo at
the unfair coin well here we're also
well here we're doing what
what we want we're rejecting the null
hypothesis
so nothing too interesting over here
similar to before but also similar to
before we have the same problem in which
we're biased you see we want 65 percent
we're at about 72 percent and look how
many times it accepted 85 percent or
more even though the ground truth is 65
so beijing sorry so um hdi plus rope
doesn't magically sell for the problem
but it is beneficial over nhst for three
main reasons first you can accept the
null hypothesis um second you get a
descriptive distribution of your
posterior uh and in the previous talk
you heard all about adding prior beliefs
that's beyond the scope of my talk but
um but yeah
that's another advantage uh so precision
is the goal that's the uh that's the
idea that i'm echoing from uh john
krusk's uh learnings in which basically
it's the same idea as hdi plus rope but
actually the stop criteria is based on
the width of the
hdi so what i mean by that is you take
you define your precision goal in
advance how much should that be well
some fraction of the rope so let's say
uh so it's commonly used 80 is commonly
used so let's take that as an example
and so the stop criterion is just when
the hdi is smaller than the precision
goal then you stop and you assess an
assessment is the same as before so just
for example regardless of where it is
compared to the null hypothesis i
purposely didn't draw the null
hypothesis regardless of where it is if
it's broader than than the precision
goal then you continue collecting if
it's narrower then you stop and assess
so here for example here it's going to
be rejected and here it's the same exact
width but um
but it happens to be within the rope and
so you accept
and of course if you're struggling then
you're going to be inconclusive okay so
it sounds promising let's uh see what
the results actually are so i forgot the
title over here but the same cumulative
uh probability of decision making at the
stop criterion and so here you can see a
few interesting things first of all the
good thing is that it solves the problem
for not uh oh sorry i should have
mentioned so here i'm using the fear
fair coin again uh it's all the problem
that we're not accepting the null
hypothesis anymore we're rejecting it
okay but there is something problematic
that you you're probably seeing is that
we're accepting the null hypothesis only
40 percent of time and 60 of the time
were actually inconclusive and so that's
a massive issue
with this um and so i'll address that
very soon
um here i'm looking at an unfair coin
and here's con and this is kind of what
you expect
you're rejecting the null hypothesis
it's a bit slower than before as you
expect
and it's more like a heavy heavy side
step function
uh and but the beautiful thing is this
graph over here is that here you have
the true rate the sample sorry the
samples mean agrees with the true rate
so even though you're you're
inconclusive when the ground truth is a
fair coin uh you know if it's an unfair
coin you know that well in both cases
you know that you're getting an accurate
result even though you're inconclusive
you are accurate about um
sorry when um
when you are accepting you know uh you
know you are accurate um yeah so so so
that's a great advantage of precision is
the goal and um
yeah but of course the the main
challenge is inconclusive so when i was
trying to apply this in my line of work
well i
i also had to kind of like wing it like
get around like how do i deal with
inconclusive and so uh one anecdote i
had that a while the the picture i was
showing is that um um my baby daughter
was lying on me and i was creating these
slides i was also quoting things up and
so i did make a mistake and i very had a
very fortunate mistake in which i found
that actually i think we can do better
than precision is the goal and that's
what i want to address right now is
something i call conservative precision
is the goal uh and so it's the same
thing as pursuing the goal but we can
improve this
problem with inconclusiveness and
basically uh what i coded by mistake was
this uh was this algorithm i basically
combined both together i said that and
it's just a matter of like one or two
lines of code and so i'm saying bo you
need both the hdi to be smaller than the
precision so that's precisely the goal
and then i'm using the hdi plus stroke
the hdi is completely within the rope or
completely without right so it's easy
mistake to make
and so here i'm showing that if you're
straddling that you continue to collect
but if you're completely within or
without then you can stop
and so the beautiful thing is uh the the
plot on the right and with initial
appreciate that let's look at what we
saw before
so here is so here i'm focusing on a
fair coin
uh and so the problem with hdi plus rope
remember i talked about the fact that
we're rejecting 20 percent of the time
and then we said well we're in precision
the goal improves that by does it it it
completely rejects the sorry it doesn't
reject the null hypothesis but the
problem was that it's inconclusive and
what i call the conservative precision
is the goal actually
um it has a benefit of of both worlds in
which it's except
eventually it will always accept and it
won't be inconclusive so you can
continue collecting data so i'm quite
psyched about that i'll probably drop a
note to john kruskan and see if maybe
somebody else came up with it but uh i
was glad that i i caught on to it by
mistake uh so that was a fair coin uh
here it with an unfair coin i get the
same result as precision as a goal which
is good and not compromising on accuracy
um yeah so
that is um yeah that's precision is the
goal but of course we have to talk about
real life uh um how do we apply this in
the real world and the main reason is
that um there's always the analyst
dilemma and which on the one hand you
want to be true to the scientific method
on the other hand you want to be
attentive to stakeholders need to be as
cost effective as possible and so the
way to get around this is to be ensure
that you have a clear objective
if there's time later then i'll show you
uh a demo on streamlight that i've done
um but i like this quote by john krusk
in which he talks about the fact that
the samples that you want to be clear
when when deciding your sample size you
want to be clear on your objective and
speak with stakeholders i know it's kind
of like a fuzzy territory because they
come with me with different court with
different questions um and
and in practice it means
different sample sizes for different
questions and that's what i want to get
through right now what do i mean by that
and so they post different questions in
which as an analyst i translate into
different numbers of parameters because
the more parameters you have to deal
with that's going to be more expensive
in order of sample size for for to get a
significant result and that's what i'm
illustrating these three plots over here
okay so i'll just go one by one through
them just so you understand what it
means so the first question is i'm asked
how well does the model perform like
give me a number and so
if i think
of course it depends on your domain but
going back to the coin toss which is a
useful analogy well all i need is two
parameters i need to know how many times
i've tossed and what what what rate have
i been successful and then i can tell
them like give them some sort of
distribution of how well the model
performs okay so that's one type of
sample size but if they ask me something
different let's say look we have to pass
a certain threshold we have to pass like
70
what's the probability that we're
passing through 70 well that's another
parameter that we have to improve upon
right and so um
and so that might impact the sample size
so you want to count take that into
account if you do precision is the goal
method or anything else okay another
thing
then of course the most popular question
is is variant a better than variant b
right so now you have like two different
coins right
is one coin biased is the other unbiased
or whatever combination and so that's
four parameters right that's uh how much
are you tossing one tossing the other
and how successful are you are you in
each so the more parameters that will
impact your sample size so you want to
define this in advance
and so my point being is that um
you want to be as clear as possible in
order to determine your sample size and
um and the reason being is when you're
planning your budget all your data is
hypothetical and so you have a lot of
parameters to play with and so that's
one thing that um
in my calculator that i'm looking into
is like how uh
how to how to
change the different variables where of
course the more easy thing is once the
data is a stated fact and then how do
you interpret it
and avoid misinterpretation as i talked
about before uh and so we're at 30
minutes um i'm going to spend the next
five minutes uh summarizing i'll like we
said if this time later we'll go into
this uh calculator i created but in any
case it's online feel free to go on to
it
um
yeah so thank thanks to streamlet that
that hosted it's really brilliant i
actually couldn't get it to work on my
laptop at the last minute so i'm very
thankful that they have it up up and
running uh okay so i'll just skip these
these are just my working examples on
the calculator um one thing my
calculator does it does not include at
the moment is what people are most
interested in is a b testing but so i
will point you to very useful resources
online uh john cruz has an excellent
paper called best promoting the idea of
beijing statistics um
there's an alternative approach instead
of a
precision is the goal something called
expected loss criterion by chris
struchier so you want to look him up
when you're comparing methods even
miller has excellent um material and
calculators himself and um i like this
blog post that actually summarizes all
three so uh yeah
i very much encourage looking that up
um
i do not oh i clicked that i clicked his
site by accident
um
sorry
do not know why
okay um yeah so if i've done a good job
today hopefully you have a better
understanding of experimentation
and what i'm encouraging you to do has
is improved the way that you interpret
data and by that you'll be able to
improve how you budget for collection of
data where my main take-home messages
are
you should start using bayesian
methodology as a role as opposed to the
frequentest and of course precision is
expensive to those who manage to dig a
bit deeper with me i'll just summarize
the the key topics um the um i talked
about the problem with the extreme
extreme methods for the stop criterion
the frequencies and nhst and the hdi
plus rope i showed that they
they're likely to to give you biased
results if it's confirmation biased or
just the sample uh sample rate
will be biased and i encourage precision
as the goal as as a methodology when it
comes to bayesian uh in general you want
to use that because it's more
interpretable and in terms of hypothesis
testing is because you're more likely to
because you'll be able to accept the
null hypothesis something you cannot do
with frequentist hypothesis testing
there's many topics in this field so i'm
just highlighting a whole marriott in
which i haven't had time to address if
it's power calculations uh usage of
priors multiply hypothesis testing is a
huge issue for frequentist it's not an
issue for bayesians um
i was talking i used analytical
solutions very simple uh coin toss
before you how to talk about numerical
solutions in which you want to use pi mc
and a whole field of stratification of
cohorts of course that makes life much
more complicated i kept things very
simple um just to summarize
yeah hypothesis testing i find it
requires defining a clear objective in
planning so you can
have a realistic budget and a good
interpretation of your data we talked
about the fact that nhst and hdi plus
rope yield biasing results and um
precision is the goal gives accurate
results it does have the issue of
inconclusiveness when you happen when
the null hypothesis happens to be true
and i suggested an alternative as the
conservative uh
uh precision is the goal um
as a possible improvement uh just before
i i give time for questions i want to
mention if you enjoy this talk uh just
self promotion i have two other talks
that i've uh um
delivered in previous uh conferences one
is just a gentle introduction to uh
causal inference uh and the other is a
uh is a tutorial in which you learn
about most a topic that's called it's a
mouthful it's multi-objective
optimization effectively what it is how
do you deal with two or more
objective parameters that might uh
contradict each other or be in conflict
and so that's a topic called pareto
fronts which i'm pretty enthusiastic
about and i created uh jupiter notebooks
with demos
so yeah so with that i'll take questions
from here
thank you very much and i have the first
question
yeah interesting the conservative pitg
thanks for the talk by the way uh first
question is
is it a robust also over like multiple
different types of data generating
data generating processes because in
this case
it performed really well but have you
tested it also in with other data
generating processes
and then the second question is
if you would add to it that it doesn't
like
peak at every iteration but maybe only
every
100 iterations would that be
would it make it even more robust or
okay so uh just to reiterate the
question thank you for the questions um
so the first question is uh he pointed
out the fact that i used it only on
bernoulli statistics just a coin flip um
which is rates but of course you can use
like uh continuous variables let's say a
gaussian distribution or something like
that or something more complicated the
answer is no i'm assuming that these are
useful analogies but i haven't looked
into that
i didn't understand your second your
second question um
well
yeah i also use the analogy that it's
kind of like peaking is kind of like
risk of ruin right if you like uh peak
too often the chance of
uh
seeing a certain outcome that's wrong is
increases so but you kind of want to
keep collecting data yeah so couldn't
you like keep collecting data but every
only every 100th iteration you're
allowed to
uh apply that stopping condition you
know if
i see excellent question um so so the
question is okay so let's say um you get
a result um i'm assuming let's say it's
inconclusive how do we um
how do we uh continue when we're
inconclusive and so my opinion is uh
when i applied it
i like precision is the goal because you
define your precision and then you just
um
and
well if you're inconclusive about the
precision well just define your next
precision how much you want to go to and
that's kind of something that i played
with my stakeholders in which we got to
an inconclusive result and then we just
continue collecting we define in advance
how much more data we need well the idea
that was the following is when we decide
the person is is the goal i defined like
how much sample i want to collect
but the
the the sample rate we got was different
from the base one and so i said okay
that's no problem considering
we
got a different base we got a different
result from our base we still have the
precision if we collect more let's wait
till we get to that precision because i
was bound by stakeholders who have a
budget they don't care about precision
they care about how how many samples
should we collect that was the main
problem with stakeholders they don't
care about precision
as an analyst i care about precision
they care about n number so what
happened is i give them a number the the
truth happened to be different from the
base that i assumed and said that's no
problem i still have my precision goal
i give them here's the next number that
we want to go to so that kind of answers
your question we started and so that
that enables me to not pee look enables
me actually to peak because i'm fine
with peaking because uh my goal is the
precision
yeah so if that was incoherent i should
have prepared probably better on that
yeah
thank you for the presentation so um
do you think that this method could be
applied uh with
frequency confidence interval because
um i had
i struggled before to justify the use of
hdi in high data regime when
confidence interval and hdi tends to
overlap quite massively from a practical
point of view
and
to go if you have a friendly stakeholder
that listen to you it's fine but if you
have someone that is
fair strongly convinced that
uh
i don't know frequencies methods are the
way to go uh do you think we could apply
this uh this methodologies in a
frequency framework
uh well i'll show you two
one thing that uh uh i'll just the thing
so your question is uh should could we
use confidence interval when working
with stakeholders especially with
stakeholders when they're um because
stakeholders they understand frequentist
and not asian
[Music]
sorry or apply the
[Music]
precision method that you specify today
using confidence interval obviously
correcting for alpha i see
interesting um
okay you thank you for that question i i
haven't looked into that but i i do want
to flag um
like
like i i believe like showing like
stakeholders like visuals help them like
get them from frequency to bayesian so i
think i'll i'll just like that i'm just
looking up a hidden slide that i had um
yeah here um
can you see this
yeah you can see this okay so here i'm
showing basically my point my point
before was that frequentness invasion
yield the same result if you collect
enough data that's what i'm showing here
on the left so here 3 000. so in orange
i'm showing the uh credible interval for
the posterior of of
of just a better distribution and you
can see here i'm showing like the
frequentest something called the
aggressive call in which here's their 95
percent so in that sense they agree you
collect enough data that's great you can
show that but what you want to show your
stakeholder is what happens if you're
running a budget let's say 30 right your
size is 30. well here you can see
they're a mismatch right an aggressive
coal actually if you look at the formula
you can get more than a rate of a
hundred percent
and so it's really awkward conversation
so what i do i just sit with the sake
i'll just show them like this is why i
want to shift to beijing thinking it
requires a bit more thought but it's
worth
well worth it it's much more just
descriptive and and so it's more
interpretable where frequentist is not
um yeah so so that's one answer plus the
other is that nhst
you cannot
accept the null hypothesis you can only
rule it out
fantastic can we just have one more
question
thank you so much for the presentation i
have a question about rope specifically
about rope
um
so
in many cases i understand that you can
specify the region of practical
equivalence and maybe it's based on your
business logic that something is you
know generally applicable
or equivalent in some cases you might
not know specifically what that
equivalence might be so let's say you
hope that a feature brings you on
average a thousand euros per day or per
given time interval if it's between 990
and 1010 maybe that's okay
but maybe 950 and 1050 is already okay
it's a bit more uncertainty and and
maybe different ropes might give you
different answers in the first place and
i'm just trying to understand whether
you can use rope or instantiate it as a
random variable with some also priors
and then you see you can see how your
results change based on these priors on
your rope
yeah no that's an excellent question so
just to summarize the question how do
you know if your rope is correct or
should that should be another parameter
that you've been playing around with um
so i'll give you my generic answer
anything that has to do with
subjectivity and statistics is that um
a lot of people believe that statistics
is is like an objective field but no
like there's always going to be
subjectivity some
finger in the wind and
our our job is to do something that um
that that that is reasonable and we have
to convince first ourselves and then our
stakeholders you're asking specifically
about rope yeah that's something that i
play around with just to see what's
reasonable
my stakeholder has a budget and so i
cannot bring the rope to be too small
and so i need the but i need uh
let's say in my case i couldn't go more
than a thousand samples and so my rope
i have to determine such that i'm not
going to pass a thousand sample
regardless of um where the result is
going to be if it's around nine well you
have a prior notion of what the base
right that's power part of your
calculation of where your base is going
to be is it about 90 or is around 70
that will have a massive impact on your
sample size
um
so yeah
i appreciate that i haven't fully
answered the question but i guess the
answer is you just have to play around
with it um
would it be equivalent to picking um
so
oh you i see
no oh i see your question so your
question is should i determine rope in
advance or after
okay um well no you should you should do
it in advance yeah
you should do it in advance um i don't
have any experience like doing it after
so i yeah i'm not sure how to answer
that question but just from reading from
from john chris material yeah that's
something you wanted to determine the
precision and the rope in advance
so i hopefully answered your follow-up
question i don't know about your first
one